HOW MANY POINTS WILL TRAE YOUNG
SCORE?
WE ASKED YOU IN THE APP HOW MANY
POINTS WILL TRAE YOUNG SCORE
AGAINST THE BUCKS.
LET US KNOW, GET IN THE
COMMENTS, TELL ME HOW MANY
POINTS TRAE YOUNG IS PUTTING UP
AT THE END OF THE GAME, WE'LL
SEE ONE PERSON WHO GETS THE
CLOSEST AND HOOK UP WITH WITH A
JERSEY OF YOUR CHOICE.
28 1/2.
DO YOU LIKE THAT NUMBER?
>> TRAE YOUNG TO ME IS LIKE THAT
GNAT, YOU SBAT HIM AND HE
DOESN'T GO AWAY.
THE HAWKS TOOK THREE GAMES FROM
PHIL.
Y.
THE BUCKS AND HAWKS MET THREE
TIMES, THE BUCKS TWO GAMES, TRAE
YOUNG ONE OF THOSE THREE GAMES
AND HAPPENS TO BE IN A LOSS,
POSTED 15 POINTS, SIX TURNOVERS
AND WENT 0 FOR 3 FROM BEYOND THE
ARC, ALL THANKS TO DREW
HOLLIDAY.
TRAE IS AVERAGING 29 POINTS PER
GAME IN THE PLAYOFF SO FAR HE'S
CLUTCH.
TONIGHT I TAKE THE UNDER 28 1/2,
HOLLIDAY IS ABSOLUTELY GOING TO
SLOW HIM DOWN.
NOW ANOTHER INTERESTING STAT
THAT I READ THIS MORNING, GREG,
YOUNG IS 1 FOR 10 IN HIS CAREER
WHEN HOLLIDAY THE CLOSEST
DEFENDER ON HIS SHOTS.
TRAE YOUNG UNDER 28 1/2 POINTS.
>> ERIN IF ANYBODY WAS DIGGING
IT UP -- IT
>> IT WAS ME.
>> IT'S NOBODY OTHER THAN YOU
AARON DOUGH LON SHOUT OUT FOR
DIGGING UP THE INTERESTING
STATS.
LET ME GIVE AWAY SOME HOODIES.
HOW MANY POINTS WILL TRAE YOUNG
SCORE?
I'M IN THE COMMENTS RIGHT NOW
LOOKING FOR TAKES, LOOKING FOR
TAK
TAKES.
TRA SE SCORING 36 TONIGHT, ERIN?
>> I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THAT.
I FEEL LIKE HE'S ALWAYS ON THAT.
>> SHOUT OUT TO NOT RONALD
ACUNYA JR.
I ALSO SEE SKATE WITH AN 8,
LOSING BY THE HOOK.
THE UNDER IS WINNING BY THE
HOOK.
MOVING RIGHT ALONG RICHIE 21
SAYS 26 POINLTS, SHOUT OUT TO
EVERYBODY I JUST MENTIONED, YOU
ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A HOODIE.
IT'S HARD FOR ME TO DIG IN HERE
AND THIS MILWAUKEE BUCKS TEAM
THEY FACED THE NETS.
THE NETS, K.D., JAMES HARDEN,
KYRIE IRVING EARLY ON IN THE
SERIES AND THEY WERE CONSTANTLY,
I MEAN, YOU KNOW, IT WAS LOW
SCORING.
IT WAS A LOW SCORING AFFAIR.
>> VERY.
>> THIS NEXT TEAM USED TO, THEY
PUT UP 140, 130 WITH EASE DURING
THE REGULAR SEASON.
>> YEP.
>> I THINK THAT TREND OF DEFENSE
IS GOING TO CONTINUE IN THIS
ONE.
I DO THINK THE BUCKS WILL HAVE
THE CLAMPS AND YOU JUST
MENTIONED YOUR INTERESTING STAT,
WITH DREW HOLIDAY GUARDING TRAE
YOUNG, SHOUT OUT TO YOU ERIN I'M
ROCKING WITH THE UNDER 28 1/2.
I SEE A LOT OF DEFENSE WILL BE
PLAYED TONIGHT AND REMEMBER
WE'RE GOING TO HIT ONE OF YOU
GUYS UP AFTER THE GAME AND HOOK
YOU GUYS UP WITH A JERSEY BUT I
GOT MORE JERSEYS TO GIVE AWAY
RIGHT NOW SO LET'S HEAD OVER TO
THE NEXT SEGMENT, ERIN, I WAS
LOOKING AT THE SERIES ODDS FOR
THE HAWKS AND BUCKS AND SAW THE
HAWKS ARE ACTUALLY BEING OFFERED
AT PLUS 2 1/2 GAMES.
>> YEP.
>> I PUT THE ODDS UP RIGHT
THERE.
THERE IT IS PLUS 2 1/2 GAMES.
THAT MEANS THAT THEY ONLY HAVE
TO WIN TWO GAMES IN THE SERIES
FOR THIS BET TO CASH, ERIN.
>> IT'S CRAZY.
YOU DON'T THINK THEY'LL DO THAT
BUT THEY PLAYED AGAINST THE
KNICKS AND MY PHILADELPHIA 6ers
ABSOLUTELY UPSETTING THEM.
IT'S HARD TO DOUBT THIS TEAM.
>> RIGHT, IT IS HARD TO DOUBT
THIS TEAM BUT WHAT I NEED YOU
GUYS NOT TO DOUBT IS GET IN THE
AND TELL ME IF THE HAWKS ARE
GOING TO WIN THE SERIES.
I'LL GIVE AWAY A JERSEY.
ERIN THIS SEEMS JUICY TO ME.
NO?
>> I SEE WHY THIS IS ENTICINENT.
I DON'T SEE THE SERIES GOING
SEVEN GAMES.
IF YOU THINK ATLANTA IS GOING TO
WIN AT LEAST TWO GAMES GO FOR IT
NOW.
THE HAWKS ARE RELENTLESS IN THE
SERIES AGAINST THE 76ers.
IF YOU THINK THE BUCKS ARE GOING
TO WIN SO WE COULD SWEEP ATLANTA
AND WIN THE SERIES.
I LEAN MORE TOWARD THE BUCKS BUT
IN ALL HONESTY I FEEL MORE
CONFIDENT STAYING AWAY FROM THE
MARKET UNTIL AFTER GAME ONE.
>> THERE IS NOTHING WRONG WITH
STAYING AWAY, NOTHING WRONG WITH
STAYING AWAY.
ERIN, LET ME GET INTO THE
COMMENTS IF THEY STAYED AWAY OR
ROLLED WITH THE HAWKS OR
MILWAUKEE.
I SEE PEPE, 00, HOPEFULLY I DID
NOT BUTCHER YOUR NAME, BUCKS
4-1.
BALLER 2021 SAYS BUCKS IN SIX.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU BALLER 2021,
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
ERIN, TIME TO GIVE AWAY A JERSEY
IN THE COMMENTS.
>> LOTS OF JERSEY TO GIVE AWAY
TODAY.
>> LOTS OF JERSEYS TO GIVE AWAY.
HERE WE GO, I SEE, HOLD ON, I'M
STILL LOOKING.
I'M STILL LOOKING.
I GOT MGOBLUE IN THE COMMENTS.
RICH BARTELS SAYS MILWAUKEE IN
FOUR, SHOUT OUT TO YOU, RICH
BARTELS, YOU ARE WALKING AWAY
WITH A JERSEY.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
JERSEY.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
I TALKED ABOUT YOUR INTERESTING
STAT OF DREW HOLIDAY GUARDING
TRAE YOUNG.
I TALKED ABOUT THE DEFENSE
APPLIED FROM THE MILWAUKEE TEAM
AND I DON'T SEE ANYTHING
CHANGING HONESTLY.
I'M TAKING THE BUCKS MINUS
2 1/2.
THEY MIGHT SWEEP, ERIN, HONESTLY
THEY MIGHT SWEEP.
I HAVE ONE MORE JERSEY TO GIVE
AWAY SO LET'S DEEP MOVING ACTION
THE CLIPPERS ARE TWO GAMES DOWN
TO THE SUNS BUT THEY'VE COME
BACK FROM TWO GAMES DEFICIT
TWICE ALREADY THIS YEAR.
CAN THEY DO IT AGAIN WITH NO
KAWHI?
LET'S LOOK AT THE ODDS FOR THE
CLIPPERS TO WIN THE SERIES.
GET IN THE COMMENTS AND TELL ME
IF YOU THINK IT'S WORTH A
SPRINKLE.
I'M GIVING AWAY HOODIES.
ERIN, WHAT IS YOUR TAKE?
>> CAN THE CLIPPERS COME BACK,
POSSIBLY, BUT WILL THEY, THE
ULTIMATE QUESTION.
GAME TWO IS SO EXCITING.
THE CLIPPERS HAD IT AND SHOULD
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO WIN THAT GAME
BUT ON VEETSLY THEY DID NOT.
THE CLIPPERS NEED TO WIN
BACK-TO-BACK GAMES AT HOME TO
GIVE ME ANY FAITH IN THIS TEAM.
I KNOW THIS PRICE PLUS 540 IS
ENTICING.
WE SAW THIS TYPE OF NUMBER WHEN
THE BUCKS WENT DOWN TWO GAMES
RIGHT AWAY AGAINST THE NETS.
NOW THEY'RE THE FAVORITE TO WIN
THE TITLE BUT TO ME THE CLIPPERS
COMING BACK DEPENDS ON THE
HEALTH AND AVAILABILITY OF KAWHI
LEONARD.
HE STAYED IN L.A. TO NURSE AND
REHAB HIS KNEE OVER THE LAST TO
TWO-GAMES.
WE WAIT HIS STATUS FOR GAME
THREE AND CHRIS PAUL DOES INTEND
TO COME BACK FOR GAME THREE, A
TOUGH SPOT LOOKING AT THE NUMBER
IT'S JUICY AND THE CLIPPERS ARE
GOING TO HEAD HOME FOR THE TWO
GAMES.
IT'S WORTH A LOOK AND A SPRINKLE
OF MONEY BUT ULTIMATELY I THINK
THE SUNS ARE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
WIN THE SERIES AND THE CLIPPERS
WILL BOUNCE BACK.
>> ERIN IS ROCKING WITH THE
SUNS.
I AM IN THE COMMENTS RIGHT NOW.
I SEE WHAT A GUY 24 HAS A GIF OF
A SUNSET.
CLIPPERS DOESN'T HAVE A CHANCE.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU, WHAT A GUY 24
WALKING AWAY WITH A HOODIE.
I'M GIVING AWAY ONE MORE.
>> DO IT.
>> PAR LAY PICKER 48 SAYS HOT
TAKE, CLIPPER ALSO WIN THE NEXT
GAME BUT THEY CANNOT COME BACK
FOR GOOD DUE TO PANDEMIC P.
I DON'T KNOW HOW I FEEL ABOUT
THAT.
SHOUT OUT TO PAR LAY PICKER 48,
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
SHIRT.
IN THE FIRST ROUND THEY CAME
BACK FROM A 2-0 DEFICIT.
SECOND ROUND CAME BACK FROM A
2-0 DEFICIT.
THE CLIPPERS HAVE BEEN HERE
BEFORE.
THEY'RE AT PLUS 540, IT'S WORTH
A LITTLE SPRINKLE IN MY OPINION,
THEY SHOULD HAVE WON LAST NIGHT.
THEY'RE TAKING IT BACK TO L.A.
MIGHT GET KAWHI BACK BUT I'M
KIND OF CONFIDENT IN THE
CLIPPERS BEING ABLE TO COME BACK
FROM 2-0 BECAUSE I JUST SAW IT
TWICE IN THIS PLAYOFFS.
>> YOU THINK THEY COULD DO IT A
THIRD TIME NOW?
>> I MEAN THIRD TIME'S THE
CHARM.
>> TRUE.
THAT IS THE SAYING.
>> YOU KNOW, SO WE WILL SEE.
I GOT ONE MORE JERSEY TO GIVE
AWAY IN THE NEXT SEGMENT, WE GOT
TWO HEAVY FAVORITES IN THE
CONFERENCE FINALS AND WE GOT TWO
HEAVY FAVORITES IN THE
CONFERENCE FINALS, THE SUNS, THE
SUNS ARE IN FACT MINUS 770 TO
WIN THE WEST AGAINST THE BUCKS.
THE BUCKS ARE MINUS 500 TO WIN
THE EAST.
WE SEE THE CLIPPERS AT PLUS
1500, WE SEE ATLANTA AND PHOENIX
AND MILWAUKEE, GET IN THE
COMMENTS AND TELL ME WHICH TEAM
IS A BETTER BET TO WIN IT ALL.
BUCKS, SUNS, ERIN, WHAT DO YOU
THINK?
THERE'S BETTER VALUE ON THE
LONGER SHOTS LIKE THE CLIP
CLIPPERS.
I DON'T THINK THE CLIPPERS WILL
ADVANCE.
IN YOUR CASE, GREG, MAYBE YOU
WANT TO PUT MONEY ON THEM AT
15-1.
ANOTHER THING WHEN THE BUCKS
WERE DOWN TWO GAMES AGAINST THE
NETS THEY MOVED TO 16-1 TO WIN
IT ALL AND LOOK AT THEM PLUS
105, THAT WILL BE A GREAT PAYDAY
FOR ANYBODY ABLE TO GRAB THEM AT
16-1 TO WIN IF THE BUCKS DO
THAT.
FOR ME I TAKE THE BUCKS PLUS
MONEY BETWEEN THE FAVORITES THAT
I LIKE AT THE MOMENT.
>> SHOUT OUT TO YOU, ERIN, SHOUT
OUT TO YOU.
YOU ARE ROCKING WITH THE BUCKS.
LET ME GET INTO THE COMMENTS AND
SEE WHAT THE FANS ARE ROCKING
WITH.
I GOT RYAN RAY SAYS SUNS SHOUT
OUT TO YOU, WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
I GOT ONE HARLEY SENIOR, BUCKS
WILL WIN IT ALL, HE'S ROCKING
WITH THE BUCKS, SHOUT OUT TO
YOU, ONE HARLEY SENIOR AND ONE
MORE HOODIE TO GIVE AWAY.
JASON WADE 13 SAYS BUCKS BEAT
THE NETS, THERE'S NOT A CHANCE
ANYONE CAN BEAT THEM.
ROCKING WITH THE NETS TO WIN IT
ALL.
>> GOOD POINT.
>> ERIN, IT IS TIME TO GIVE AWAY
OUR LAST JERSEY.
I AM IN THE COMMENTS.
IN THE COMMENTS I GOT DIALING
MONTEROSAS.
HOPEFULLY I DID NOT BUTCHER
THAT.
BUCKS IN SIX AGAINST THE SUNS,
BECAUSE OF THEIR DEFENSE.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU, BROTHER.
YOU WERE LISTENING.
I MENTIONED DEFENSE.
>> YES, MULTIPLE TIMES.
>> THEREFORE YOU ARE WALKING
AWAY WITH A JERSEY OF YOUR
CHOICE.
ERIN, I THINK THAT'S IT, MAN.
THANK YOU GUYS FOR TAPPING INTO
"THE GROUP CHAT" PRESENTED BY
FAN DUEL.
REMEMBER WHAT YOU LEARNED TODAY.
THE 3x2 IS A LOCK.
TRAE IS NOT PUTTING UP OVER
28 1/2 POINTS AND THE CLIPPERS
JUST MIGHT COME BACK WITHOUT
KAWHI.
WE'LL BE BACK NEXT WEEK, GIVING
OUT MORE HOODIES, MORE JERSEYS
AND MORE LOCKS.
IF YOU WANT A HOODIE, WE'LL DM
YOU AND YOU KNOW I'LL GIVE AWAY
ONE MORE TIME JUST FOR FUN,
ERIN?
>> A JERSEY?
OR HOODIE?
>> WHY NOT?
I'M BACK INTO THE COMMENTS
GIVING AWAY A JERSEY.
PRODUCER SAYS GIVE AWAY ANOTHER
JERSEY.
HERE WE GO, I GOT ELLIOTT WIRE
OA.
I LOVE THE SUNS BECAUSE OF CP3'S
LEADERSHIP AND D.A.'S
IMPROVEMENT ON DEFENSE.
THAT SAY HOT TAKE.
THAT IS A HOT TAKE.
ALONGSIDE AARON DOLAN, UG
ER
GREG IVORY AND WE'RE LEAVING THE
"GROUP CHAT."
>> BYE GUYS.